I want to start my own company through
YouTube but at the same time manage our
relationship and studies and be the
president my class any tips so once we
an entrepreneur once have a relationship
wants to do well at school as well what
tips do you have to manage all of that
um well I mean definitely scheduling it
doesn't have to be so rigid or like
you're creating a calendar entry right
but definitely compartmentalizing your
day so that when you are focusing on one
of those priorities you're really just
focusing on that priority all right so
like you can be out to out to a meal
like a nice dinner with with your
significant other if your mind is over
here you know thinking about your
business or thinking about being
president of your class or you know
getting a pub with youtube so i think
that's really important and this might
be like super philosophical and
metaphysical but you know just in the
moment you know keep price so like what
you working on your business or fun your
business when her what's your
significant other be present with just
another i think that that's really
important because what happens is i know
you'll end up getting maybe even stand
there on 100 things but you end up
getting a hundred percent there on zero
things you know so like you really want
to compartmentalize from focus i think
that that's really important um and the
other thing I would recommend is is you
know you this question you know you seem
to have some tangible goals write down
those goals and put them on a sticky
note or put them on a post-it note and
put them on your your computer like
whatever ever you are most of your time
just visualize those goals and if you
can you know drill down and it's kind of
weird with personal relationships but
you know it's real down don't like what
the metrics are that you're going to
determine you know you were successful
meeting those goals so being president
of your class that's a clear metric
right um you either of you are you
aren't president of the class but you
know in terms of starting a YouTube
business um figuring out like how many
subscribers are you cheap trying to
attain or how many yeah how much revenue
if you want to make with your youtube
business you know so like being able to
set tangible goals make them visible and
constantly refer back to them um you
know to keep yourself on track those
would be my rent yeah I love it i I'm on
the same page I think any any major
thing that you have in your life you
want the dedicate time to you have to
block out those chunks in your calendar
and so if it's you know with your
girlfriend then maybe those are in the
evenings and if you have to study
certain amounts of time you know you
blocked in your calendar you want to
focus on YouTube you blocking your
calendar it's not in your calendar you
don't dedicate the time and chunks to it
you're probably not going to do it
because life has a funny way of just
getting in the way of everything that
you're trying to do and to the point on
focus i really love that and i think
it's easy as entrepreneurs to get
distracted I know for myself I'm with my
wife and with my son you know we may be
a plane in the park and like boom idea
hits right like I gotta go do this and
and it's easier then get derailed and
want to think about that and not
actually be present with my wife and my
mind my son and what I find the easiest
way for me is I just said myself an
email like as long as I can get it out
of my head and I know it can come back
to it then I feel safe and kind of
moving on but if I haven't written it
down I haven't sent myself that note
that i'm gonna keep thinking about it
and I'm worried that I'm gonna forget it
and then not be focused on being present
and being with my wife in my sign so
it's a pretty low like so send an email
write it down i think i would expect
those things to happen expect those kind
of distractions that happen and and have
a plan around it so that you don't get
to cut up and you know leave it off the
wrong path and then not be able to spend
time with your with your family